Human history,
is the story of one terrible
catastrophe after another.
I, for once, would love
to wake up magically
in a better world.
Sylvie: What makes you think
the world is going
to get better?
Marshall: Today people get their
energy from the sun.
Humans have set foot on Mars.
Cancer has been defeated.
And yet, for every
question answered,
another one appears.
Here's what you need to
know about global warming.
It will all go to shit at
the end of the century.
We'll be dead,
we'll have to miss it.
But we'll be smiling in
gold plated coffins.
This is not the life
that I envisioned it to be.
The man whose house is on fire
is incredibly easy
to negotiate with.
We cannot give up and go home.
For one simple reason.
We already are home.
This is our only home.
I think it helps to look at
climate change like a bear.
The whole planet's
been wrestling
with the bear for decades.
So far, the bear's
been kicking our ass.
Nick: What if we were able
to develop technology that
would allow us to survive,
maybe even thrive?
Jonathan: You don't know what's
going to happen.
Olivia: It won't go the way you want.
It never does.
Erza: I remember being happy.
Daddy!
What about now?
Natasha: Are you happy now?
Are we bad people?
Stop being angry about the past.
The future is now.
♪♪
Miami is dangerous.
Your mother's moving with
her sister in Chicago.
Thought you hated your sister?
It's too hot out,
to hate people
these days Marshall.
♪♪